ils sentent laurent et hubert védrine
ont un point commun olrik l'ennemi de
blake et mortimer le premier perpétue le
maléfique colonel imaginé par edgar p
jacobs les seconds lui consacre une
biographie on a reconstitué le alric du
vrai dont jacob s'est inspirée et lee
après jean van hamme et d'autres
scénariste talentueux il y a continué la
piste jacobsen
il ya certainement beaucoup de
correspondances il joue avec les vérités
et c'est le but de tout auteur but
premier de jacobs et c'est le but des
auteurs qui reprennent la série
aujourd'hui son hall rick est différent
de celui de jacob mais on va découvrir
en lisant son livre où se situe le lien
entre les deux halls rick très
intéressant est des échanges et des
discussions qui anime histoire de lire
le salon versailles et accueilli plus de
170 auteurs comme l'ancien ministre
jean-pierre chevènement
j'y trouve un public cultivé amateur de
livres et c'est toujours agréable les
débats sont de bon niveau
patient parce que j'aime la france mes
passions aussi parce que la france a
beaucoup souffert et je rappelle dans
l'introduction à mon livre que je ne
suis pas née impunément en 1939
j'ai vécu l'occupation mon père a été
fait prisonnier mais ça de ma grand-mère
a brûlé bref pour moi l'histoire c'est à
vite et très tôt dans ma vie ce qu'on
veut étoffer c'est vraiment les
rencontres pour que le public ait
davantage la possibilité de discuter
avec les auteurs et qu'on ait des débats
sur l'histoire
une cinquantaine de débats et d'échangés
était organisée existant depuis 2008 le
salon a reçu cette année plus de vingt
mille personnes